I had a CDC done and I was told that my blood cell count was normal, it looks normal on the test
too. But you said it's really not if it's over 7 minus 9.4, what does this mean? Okay so this
is kind of what I was talking about before. So normal, so there's difference about lab values,
what's the normal lab value versus the optimal value or functional range. So those ranges
differ. And the white blood cell range is probably the greatest difference
that all the blood tests out there of what's considered normal. So from a lab value most and
remember every lab you go to can have a little bit different range. There's nothing
legal about what range they think is normal. But typically white blood cell count would be like 4.0 to
11 or 11.5 would be a lab value normal range. Now an optimal range or functional range of white
blood cell count is much tighter than that. It's typically 4.5 to some some people will say the
optimal range is 6.5. I would say maybe 7 to 7.5. And then anything under that would be you know a
functional deficiency in white blood cell count. You see that a lot with cancer patients that
that are going through chemotherapy. But you can see that with people that have chronic infections
too. So a chronic infection. So let's say I have a chronic MC bar infection or something or a
chronic herpes infection or chronic you know whatever um active H. Pylora infection or something
like that. That could just drain your your immune system. Even having cancer for a long period
of time could be trading on your immune system and you could have a lower than normal. You can
have a white blood cell count with 3.5. And you have even done chemotherapy. So that's that's not good
for somebody who's tried to fight cancer. You need your white blood cell count you know up there
in normal range. But what about an elevated white blood cell count? Well the doctor said it's not
elevated. It's 9.4 and the lab ranges as it goes up to 11.5. So he said it's normal. Well I'll
guarantee you 9.4 is not normal. I've seen people with chronic Lyme disease that have had you know
that's that's common with somebody's chronic Lyme disease. Not a low white blood cell count but an
elevated white blood cell count you know that's in the 9's 10's and they've had it there for
decade with chronic Lyme disease. That's not good um and that's abnormal when I would consider
abnormal. It's outside of elevated outside of functional or optimal range. What else can cause
that? So you want to look at so if yours was 9.4 I would look at I don't remember if we asked this
question but I would look at history. That's the benefit of getting this test done on a fairly
regular basis. Okay so let's say December and I had this test done it was 9.4. What is the last
idea of a CBC with differential? Well I had a CBC back in June. What was it? It was 6.3. Okay that's
what the optimal range even. So now it's elevated to 9.4. I'd say you have an infection.
And then you that's what you look at. The differential look at it's your neutrophils elevated or
your you know your lymphocytes elevated. No no no no those are pretty normal but my ESN
ophils are elevated. Okay well then it's probably environmental allergy that's causing this.
Well it probably wouldn't be a December happening that but I've seen that with people in the spray
allergy issues there's you know they have these horrible spread allergies and do a CBC and it might be
9.4 or their ESNophils are elevated. So but then you you would look at that differential and see
where what's different between the neutrophils and lymphocytes and monocytes and ESNophils and see
what if there's imbalance there that will help you get a better picture of a differential
diagnosis of what actually could be causing the infection. Now if you went back in your history
and your history was oh back in June it was 9.2 and back in December last year it was 9.6.
That I'd say you have some sort of chronic infection going on. This isn't an acute infection
that you necessarily need to treat quote unquote treat right now. It's a more of a chronic infection
like I mentioned what you could see with Lyme disease or even chronic H. Pylori. I've seen
that with chronic H. Pylori too you could have a so with a chronic infection you could have a
suppressed white blood cell if it's just draining your white blood cell code or you could have an
elevated white blood cell code. That's that through history I mean you know the last six
months two years it's been elevated that's what you would how you'd come to that conclusion.